[music playing]
NARRATOR: When Arctic
waters turn warmer,
walruses must abandon
their melting havens
in search of food and dry land.
[music playing]
The fate of a walrus
lies in the shifting ice.
With nothing solid to rest on
and long distances to swim,
a walrus can drown
in a watery Arctic.
[music playing]
Not far from the males, females
have also been contending
with a melting refuge.
Born less than a day
ago, a pup follows
his mother into Arctic water.
With no time to lose, his mother
gives him a swimming lesson.
[music playing]
It looks like fun, but
this is serious business.
The females and the young will
soon begin their own journey
in pursuit of ice.
Their lives depend on
keeping up with Mom.